large powerful expensive graphics cards
are fun but they often require a
similarly endowed wallet in order to
afford them this can make the
achievability of high-end gaming rather
frustrating enter the rx 480 which may
just be the remedy you've been looking
for at the impressive price of around
200 us dollars a dose
[Music]
cooler masters master case maker 5
features the freeform modular system
allowing you to customize adjust and
upgrade on your own make it yours at the
link in the video description down below
jokes about the new rx naming aside the
new polaris architecture named after
what is commonly known as the north star
features amd's new and quite capable 14
nanometer finfet process which should be
especially helpful on the power
consumption side of things the fourth
generation gcn architecture in the rx
480 features 2 304 stream processors
running at a boost clock of 1 266
megahertz for a peak performance of up
to 5.8 teraflops the default memory
configurations will be four gigabytes of
gddr5 memory running at seven gigabits
per second on the reference config and
up to eight gigabytes again of gddr5
memory but running at eight gigabits per
second
on other possible variations amd has
also stated that aftermarket configs may
vary but will always feature memory
clocks of seven gigabits per second at
least all that memory will be running on
a 256 bit memory interface with a
bandwidth of 224 gigabytes per second in
terms of features we now have no no no
no no no man walkman
okay that was lame and that almost fell
but it's actually kind of cool at first
it looks like just a simple overclocking
utility and it can be but it also has
some other cool stuff as well like per
voltage point frequency offsets like the
ones we recently saw toted on the nvidia
1000 series gpus this allows you to
increase the normally linear frequency
offset curve specific amounts per
voltage point being applied to the card
this results in more control over how
your card works
great it also gives you a histogram of
the last 20 minutes of your card's
activity percentage core clock speed
memory clock speed temperature and fan
speed which should make it easier to
identify issues we'll have more fun with
wattman later when we get some
aftermarket cooled cards the card
features a cooler reminiscent of the
awesome looking aesthetic of the r9 nano
but just more cheaply there's more
plastic incorporated in the design and
in places where the nano would have had
shiny metal the 480 features glossy
plastic it also features an extension
beyond the slightly longer than a nano
pcb in order to add some more heatsink
space and incorporating the fan due to
this the six pin pcie connector doesn't
sit at the end of the card which some
people may not like
overall
on the outside i actually think it's a
pretty attractive card for this price
point if you're going for something that
isn't too in your face at least also
note that naturally there will be
aftermarket cards if you don't like it
for connectivity on the back there are
three displayport outputs compatible
with dp 1.3 hbr3 and displayport 1.4 hdr
then the hdmi port is hdmi 2.0 b for 4k
60 and hdr now for the current state of
crossfire nvidia's sli setup with the
1000 series and directx 12 was a public
relations nightmare amd is going to be
handling things in a very similar way
but leaning heavily on out of driver
control like in explicit modes for link
display adapter mode and multi-display
adapter mode not much here is changing
for the vast majority of users on the
amd side in in a visible way so just
check out my video on sli for more info
as much of it is crossover and it's
probably going to be fine but all the
features in the world aren't worth an
election in north korea if the
performance isn't up to par so let's
take a look at some numbers amd promised
a high level of performance at a price
point of just 200 and they mostly
delivered on that performance at 1440p
was mostly on par with the gtx 970 in
current titles with the rx 480 breaking
40 fps in all of our benchmarks with the
settings cranked and even blew away the
970 in hitman though that is a heavily
amd optimized title the rx480 is even
capable of playable frame rates at 4k
with the settings turned down a bit to
around medium now this isn't a top-end
card but it wasn't designed to be the
goal was to raise the bar at the 200
mark and given that the cheapest gtx 970
on the market at the time of writing
this review was 260 dollars amd has put
forth an extremely compelling card for
budget conscious gamers who are looking
for the quintessential millennium falcon
of graphics cards something that isn't
flashy but has it where it counts
especially when you consider that it
matches the gtx 970 a car that was
considered the sweet spot for high-end
gaming until the 1070s release a few
weeks ago and for significantly less
money
i'd go even as far as to say if you
don't have the cash for a geforce 10
series and just care about raw
performance rather than aesthetics or
manufacturer exclusive features like
ansel or smp or something like that
there's no reason to buy gtx 970 anymore
now that the rx 480 is on the market the
480 was a smart move from amd competing
against nvidia's 1080 would have been a
little crazy shooting for the value
option was smart as it fits something
that people are actually asking for and
beating out nvidia's recently price
dropped cards handily in the price to
performance department was a perfect
target for them to shoot for considering
how their funds have been trending
lately hopefully the community agrees as
well
the k7xx
limited edition ruby red headphones
which are featured over on mass drop at
the link in the video description mass
drop has actually not just that but tons
of cool products that you can check out
everything from camping supplies to
keyboards to audio products like the
k7xxs that i'm showing off now the
concept over there is pretty simple the
more people commit to buy a given
product the lower the price of that
totally authentic product from the
manufacturer or an authorized
distributor gets
boom lots of people buy price goes down
spec wise the headphones i'm featuring
today are the same as the ones that i
reviewed last year which you can check
out over here with the only real
difference being that this run uses red
accents on the earcups and on the
headband like many drops this is a
limited time at limited quantity drops
so if you want a pair you're going to
have to act pretty
fast
so check them out at the link in the
video description if you're looking for
a really nice open-backed comfortable
pair of headphones
if you like this video like it if you
want a shirt you can check that out in
the video description down below and if
you want to join the forums so you can
hotly debate the hot or not specs of the
480. you can do that but like debate it
in a friendly way or something i guess
if you want to see another video
check up here that's our new 1070 review
which is like nearly twice the price but
pretty cool
i don't know how i want to outro this
we're gonna walk this way usually i walk
that way
i don't know where i'm going